just learned an Israeli court has
refused to release his sick brother
Nasser from prison
fifty-year-old NASA is serving seven
life sentences after a court convicted
him of taking part in attacks during the
second Palestinian uprising
a year ago he was diagnosed with cancer
Israel allows terminally ill prisoners
to apply for a compassionate release
but a few years ago an amendment was
introduced to the law to exclude those
charged with killing Israelis and also
this family is not ready to give up
their appealing to Israel's Supreme
Court
the only way to release NASA is by
exercising political effort we've asked
the Palestinian Authority to pressure
Israel through Egypt and Jordan all
three of them have signed agreements
with Israel they should use them for
leverage for a human case like NASA's
have been held in the occupied West Bank
took call for nasser's release
protesters say he poses no threat but
that Israel keeps him in jail to punish
him and his family
I want my son I want him to be by my
side even if it's just for one day he
wants to be among his people that he
sacrificed for the family last Saw nor
said in September and they fear it could
be the last
lost for words Naji says his brother
didn't have a chance to live spending
more than 30 years in prison
we want to know where he'll be buried
his mother has the right we have the
right to a grave site it's not only our
demand it's the demand of other
prisoners families who've lost loved
ones
for decades these families used to
demand the release of their sons now
they want their bodies even after their
deaths Israel hasn't released the bodies
of nine-palestinian prisoners in the
past five years as Ahmed fights for his
life his family is also fighting for his
right to a burial
Ibrahim al-jazeera the occupied West
Bank